going on welcome to stream Coco uh you
may notice things are a little bit
different today that's right I'm
standing up I'm holding these oculus
controllers like so uh Beth is here hi
it took a lot of cajoling is that a word
to get her here cuz she's busy she's
doing but but today we have a
special stream coca for you because
we're gonna be playing the oculus rift
so I'm not gonna be able to see anything
we're playing a game called Robo recall
which is a nice way of saying uh killing
robots it's a big robot killer thing
Jason Valle Cooper the corners back and
at about thirty minutes we're gonna have
an extended fine that come in he's going
to answer all your questions about
internships because I've been getting a
lot of questions about internships so
he'll be able to answer them all while
he's killing robots so I hope you're all
doing well let's put this thing on and
let's start killing some robots shall we
alright dude wait so Beth I think maybe
are you just gonna yell out yeah
comments wait sir can you see what's
going on I can't see anything so this
game basically is a play this will
continue but we'll go back and we'll
kind of play the beginning we did a we
recently did a clueless gamer with Conan
playing oculus rift Wilson's heart oh
goodness I gotta do this also your hands
when you do the thing your hands just
hang here like this which is a little
creepy I want to turn this down just a
bit keen I've already figured out a
problem with virtual reality which is oh
this doesn't work
this doesn't work I'm a this one
is the wait now it's real that whatever
here that's it yeah that's not real her
I need to understand just a bit alright
here we go alright ready alright so this
game is kind of fun here my hands I
think I'm part robot this actually could
be like Blade Runner the game they kind
of her like let's make a game where you
retire Androids but it's way more
exciting it better than Blade Runner
that's right I don't like the movie
Blade Runner I think it's boring and any
any movie where you need to
have a vo to see what's going to
understand what's going on
I don't think feel is for lazy people
all right here we go we're gonna play
they will play shouldn't play the first
level yeah that's good
all right so we just we're just gonna
try to speedrun this I've kind of played
all right so basically the game starts
where there's a virus that's happening
uh this is a wart let me just set the
scene for everybody this is a world in
which it's kind of like a futuristic New
York City futuristic Chicago and
everyone in the future kind of depends
on robots to do all the menial tasks
that people don't want to do such as
floor sweeper or you know uber driver or
something so but then they all start
getting getting infected with this virus
and they start going crazy oh Jesus um I
got my guns here and uh and so you have
to stop them oh yeah you can catch
bullets in this game which is cool throw
them back at robots you can also grab a
robot and tear its head off which is
cool throw it the other one there we go
and you kind of teleport around which is
pretty fun right in the head let's even
grab bully boom you killed it uh you can
teleport on top of cars which is pretty
cool this is look cool
I can't tell are people enjoying this or
not people are they were Satan's we
thank you vital yeah I mean like I don't
think we can see it in 360
I'll see if shotguns are just kind of
cool I must look like a crazy person I
hate spiders there's a guy behind me I
think or something
the graphics are dope this is the most
this is the most fun VR game I've ever
played by the way it's just unbelievably
cool
and also in this God get a week stuff to
load I also like the fact that you don't
have to ever reload in this game you
just drop your guns
which is great also they use it's
interesting because like the you know
the oculus is opposed to the vibe you
know the vibe has this is boring but the
vibe has room sensors so you can
actually move around whereas the oculus
you kind of have to stay in kind of the
same place see if I'm I'm looking down
this is the circle they want you to stay
in right here and so yeah right yeah
just doing some light housework but
where am I here oh here we go umm but
they use the teleporting to great effect
see if you if I'm teleporting here I can
determine where I'm going to end up what
direction would be facing so you just
took the stick and you go like that and
I'm facing this way which is cool so
they actually use the fact you have to
teleport with the oculus to like great
effect because when so much I'll show
you what somebody shooting at you
since you can rip apart a robot you can
you can just teleport right next to it
and just rip it apart instead of like
you know running around and moving it
stuff so
there I see you get up get up from
behind
let's tear apart some robots this really
where Z I'll hit one robot with
another's head there you go that's one
story to this uh yeah the stories you're
trying to find out why the robots have
gone crazy
the report is legs look at this I throw
a leg at that thing
good to beware your surroundings kids so
anything yeah the white circle you can
grab
I feel like this is make I feel like
this is giving me more confidence that I
actually should have about being like a
badass you know because there's like no
recoil
you can't reap yeah right I just look I
got poking people in the eye or another
do close to me
I like I'm the old runaway that you
shoot him in the back hey I look totally
crazy right that's kind of the whole
thing about BRE do you look like a mad
mad man yeah so you're trying to kind of
figure out why the robots are going
crazy and there's this woman talking you
and I kind of feel like guys
she might be in on it you know the
person isn't that like a typical
storytelling device kind of like I don't
know I don't want to ruin things for
people but there's a certain game that
Beth played that she really liked where
the narrator was on the device
gotta get that headshot yo recallers
gonna get that headshot yo let's get on
truck really maybe it's just cuz I grew
up with video games where it's like I
don't know man like I don't feel sick in
my eyes daughter
so maybe I'm supposed to live I'm not
supposed to live in a a lot of guys fine
for the ceiling supposed to live in a VR
world you know maybe I'm like neo or
something well crazy glitch it worked
I do like the comic book II feel of this
is really fun
and it because it kind of makes it less
I don't know less brutal because you're
not really killing things you're killing
robots would and everybody hates robots
you know no offense where am I going
but yes you're just joining us we're
playing a robo recall on the oculus rift
just great I got a couple of guns here I
also got a couple of shotguns over these
bad boys right here collect at least 10
bots all right all right let's collect
some Bob good bot collector
I guess I gotta grab these guys right
they grab them
Oh Danna missing not doing a good job
here dammit
Oh eight hours eight yeah it's a long
time Neil
where's the thing where is it
got him anymore robots anyway there we
go get a couple right here keep missing
where I'm supposed to be thrown where's
the other where is he really supervisor
ah heads getting cut off a little oh
sorry
everyone feel better sorry yeah this is
a great
yeah
Oh damnit I miss him
yes next scent of odd thing will be
coming in very shortly to talk to you
guys about how to get an internship
would be great
he's also be kidding also be killing
some robots which was really really fun
my god how long am I played this for
already fun oh okay good
can we come in about ten minutes so now
I think we're gonna we're just gonna go
the cool thing is like when you look
down the oculus masts cut up there's a
break here and it's weird because it's
perfectly broken where if I look down
half my hands or robot hands see like
these hands right here half a robot
hands and half more like flesh hands
guys we're all just moving towards the
singularity who's seen the most recent
trailer for Blade Runner and how dumb
does it look right am i right
totally stupid no it looks awesome okay
fair enough I haven't seen it I'm just
telling you I think Blade Runner is
boring I'm going on record as saying I
think it's very boring it should be more
of this more like shooting robots
instead it's like I don't know take the
voight-komp
test you know maybe our robots people to
I don't know maybe they've got feelings
I've seen that an attack ship off the
arm of Orion oh shut up guess what
everybody dies robots - okay I'm sorry
to say damn agent 34
we're old town we want huge that's a
cool car area with a Robo relay you know
this doesn't really look too far the
feat in the future everyone has really
cool ribs
it has an energy rifle please the book
is amazing
I mean it's written by a guy who I mean
I love philip k dick but you know he
basically just wrote all of his books on
meth and never went back in sculpture
and like so like you could tell in a lot
of his books where the others got sucks
where the head flip you could tell him a
lot of his books were like the meth
kicked in because it just starts getting
totally insane
Oh jay-z's a nice touch
can I go up here my god can I go on top
of the building whoa cool
all right this game just got it's
exponentially cooler I'm on the rooftops
guys what's happening one of my favorite
games of all time is is the Incredible
Hulk game cuz you can be able to just
run up the sides of buildings and turn
to a cannonball and just like destroy
stuff it was so fun this is nuts look at
this look at this city by the way how
cool is this
beyond Earth whoa the hell look at this
right ah Jesus
this is pretty great I gotta say be Oh
guys look these nuts oh man they even
got these nuts in the future that's cool
I don't know there's some weird
billboard here you see that whoa check
that out that's awesome
look if I shoot this thing it bounces
out that building then that building you
see that oh my that's cool
how far is gonna go um oh it's gonna hit
that other I can still see it way over
there if I shoot that Boulder what
happens gonna bounce back
nope all right fair enough
sorry I just had to see I know that was
super boring all right let's get out of
here everyone's just like Blair this is
the most boring strip Coco you've ever
done oh that's a lot of robots guys
Jesus Christ
oh man this is gonna suck this I hate
this gun by the way I know it's more
powerful but it sucks I mean they just
wanted to be like the psychos
questions about you would you recommend
VR at this point I would dump this game
no if the coolest game I've ever
played in my life I don't want to plant
I don't want to go back to real life
it's way too fun I like your glass you
have motion sickness whatever
okay you can fix the bullet-face all
right here we go
Oh spiders wanted half of these spiders
I haven't seen it I haven't seen the
first one by the way laser face laser
face mines chief snuggle buttons time to
get out of here
Jesus Christ
look at those bullets fly right by
see the teleporting is extremely cool
this game whoops whoops whoops ah yeah
sorry can you see me - the bullets are
not really laser Oh taser face
this game is incredibly hard to play and
answer questions at the same time but
I'm trying any game in VR
ooh I really liked I don't mean Skyrim
is dope oh I'm Way off the thing uh
Skyrim is great how much of this can you
can you see four people I have a
question people hope it's this exciting
to see or boring to see I wish I could
play Skyrim in real life was awesome
do you imagine like seeing a huge dragon
like imagine of that do you see that
blimp up there do you see that blimp
I'm shooting it match of that was a
dragon and you were like you know please
it look at how cool it is that's crazy
the reviews are coming in someone says
it's fine it's okay oh I like it this is
boring everyone except for me look at
this thing it's a fun looking good
alright a solid four oh man solid for
dolly it's a solid four alright how are
we going here uh you're just joining us
for playing rubble recall the oculus
rift again like I love oh that thing
whatever that thing is gonna suck I hate
this thing already
choose us alright shoot off the building
oh god what is this thing I think I just
want to grab these dudes and throw them
off the building right um that guy takes
a lot of bullet shots Oh do that throw
my building um um what was I gonna say
yeah I mean this is this game is
interesting because again I think that
it uses the teleportation which is
basically the oculus is weakness it
makes it a strength which is really cool
because it's fun just to jump everywhere
to jump around
versus like with the five kind of moved
the Conan so Pony picked the five we did
mixed reality at the YouTube space Conan
did the vibe and it was cool it really
good and this is what happens if you
move too far see can you guys see can
you see this this shield thing you can't
see it there's a there's kind of a
shield that comes up if you get too
close to something all right where we
going let's stay here
but yeah so far I think VR is really
cool I would kind of hold out on buying
it for the time being just cuz it's so
expensive and you need to have a really
fast computer and there aren't that many
amazing games yet for me I mean this
game is this scheme is one of the first
games I played oh Jesus
that I've really enjoyed it like can't
stop playing
but I will say playing this game is like
the very first time I ever played a game
it's like incredibly form
okay touch this dude
okay nachos thing apart
yeah Jordan could be a character in this
game I was gonna sure if you want to
come in but I couldn't find him I don't
know he's doing which is suspicious what
city is this where there's so many blips
fun fact there's actually I think I'm
the Empire State Building there's a
there's like a docking station for
blimps just Oh
Jesus issued rockets right at the relay
Jesus Christ
good rail over here sorry truth you see
that when I shoot those dudes cuz that's
fun there we go got him yeah why can't
why how come this rule just doesn't have
like emps like that's the thing with
robots is you can just shut them all
down with it you know what I'm saying
get it kids I want us together Robo
rabble one of the questions we got guys
what do you thing about my awesome is my
robot killing sure when I go in to kill
robots is the shirt I wear it's pretty
great basically when I fight Roombas
that's the closest thing we have to
robots right now Larry asked if you can
hear things thank you though yeah it's
all three days right yeah it's all 360s
you can hear what's going on although I
have like that that's a cool thing about
the oculus I will say here's the thing
here's my thing the PlayStation VR
headset is the most comfortable headset
by far it's so comfortable
the oculus has the coolest controllers
right because you can see I don't know
if you can see on here but when I go
like this let's see if I could look down
my hands it can sense what your fingers
are does that make sense
so you can see my hands now right so
it's like it can sense when I'm moving
my thumb I'm not touching anything but
I'm moving my phone it can sense that
same thing my finger I'm not even
pressing the button that can inset it
can sense that which school and then II
and then it's got extra buttons here
which is how you grab stuff see there's
a button in here I'm not showing this
well at all anyway there's a lot more
buttons that it's really cool and
PlayStation has the best headset
although these have this has your
earbuds built in which is great this has
the coolest controllers and I think vive
has the room sensors which is great you
know oculus only has kind of sensors
here and kind of over here so you can
move around a lot more with the vibe
Sooey which makes you a lot less motion
sick because you you know on upon a
Playstation you're just using a regular
controller whereas like here what I have
to please again that's
we will need to defend on this mission
pretty did that you dick you know let's
go back and play this mission oh hey we
can you sure some kind of
anomaly oh alright registration line
late the city senators may be the source
of the rogue signal please return to the
area investigate the anomaly alright so
yeah we think that there's somebody
who's broadcasting that's making all
these robots go crazy and kill everybody
or could you be the fact that you know
they they're upset that all the spirit
floats got cancelled ah next to dafonte
oh wait hold on of us stop this alright
so step on deck everybody to everybody
what's going on so I'm gonna wipe this
off uh we'll start you out like that why
I'm starting on like the first level how
about yeah let's do it because this is a
little bit we're getting a little
intense in here wait we didn't clap for
Nick for Nick how do we go back to quick
to hub so here's here's me play
basically you're going to have guns here
okay and guns here these are shotguns
you know pull them out these are
whatever you grab them by pressing with
the inside button got this you shoot
with the trigger and then how you move
is basically here you just put this up
let me put these on first so I can wipe
this down that's one thing guys one
thing bad about VR you know I have
sweaty hands what else have a sweaty
face that's disgusting
oh god yeah you're gonna want to put
those loops on there just dripping for
sure yeah they're disgusting
it's very intense man it's an intense
game you know alright so you grab with
the inside buttons or you shoot with
these and then when you move you're
gonna press the stick forward and let it
go it'll show you where to go and then
and you could also like press what
direction you're going so if you press
forward you'll see what I mean it was
like
if you kind of press and hold for that
you can rotate right or left and you'll
see an arrow that's how you go all right
here we go I got a mess if you're dope
here strap me up thank you dope yeah ok
here we go
lay your shirts getting some shadows oh
yeah dude got lots of colors bought that
bought the shirt in Harlem for 5 bucks
my robot killer shirt alright so kind of
step here alright so you want to go to
resume so just hit this oh yeah there
you go alright so see let the stick if
you press and hold it oh you got a hold
it okay and then when you let's see how
you can rotate and see which direction
you want to go with the stick so you
press and hold with the stick and where
the arrow is are you press and hold it
yes you know yes you you're gonna go
like this like this and then you can
determine what direction you end up in
when you let go oh like let's say so you
can't go that far yeah there you go okay
your turn back the other well good I
make sense yeah it does alright so can
you can you teleport alright so teleport
that way but hold but yeah and then like
I'm okay alright so you're gonna
teleport to that
ah okay there we go it's just Nick
teleporting that's ours alright so you
gonna teleport to the thing that glowing
thing but you want to be facing this way
the other way so kind of pressed forward
and then yeah okay just yeah you want to
teleport on to the hollow station if you
want to be pressed gonna be facing the
way the arrow
oh is it yes you got to do it with a
stick so stay stay here I know it's fine
yo what you get it's very easy
no prescient press before you let it go
rotate the stick to the way of the era
right eat the stick yep oh yeah there we
go alright everybody have a good yeah
there we go alright so you're gonna want
to go to missions and just press the top
button like this button dump that button
yeah I think go to city center yeah get
badge recall cool start mission ready to
read
all right let's do it all right so you
can't you can't reload your guns if you
run out of bullets just grab new guns
okay okay right there at your holster
okay cool there's also shotguns over
your shoulder got it all right got it
I think so is that mean Jesus see I see
you the background you can't hide I love
it wait I keep throwing my gun yeah you
got to hold onto it at the inside but
the inside one Oh got ya oh there we go
also you can grab anything with the
white circle you can grab the bullets if
you want Oh grab it grab it dude every
time you grab two at the same time oh
yeah
all right now now I'm going to ask Nick
about questions while he's doing oh my
god you get they give me like yeah we
get a double hit okay just resetting
your hit time your hips also you can
grab a robot that's a teleport
unscrewing there you go yeah baby
like over there oh yeah gone and when
you start getting shot at remember you
can you can teleport out of that I see
okay one thing I don't like about Robo
recall is I do wish that you get rid of
that scoreboard on the side too super
annoying oh this is awesome
yeah oh my god I remember view body
yeah I love the next where you at Jackie
are you sweating so are oh you can
remember you can grab this season
traffic is the same way I grab you guys
yeah going over this way I love it
with the pretty lady in the background
ah it's bad
interesting fact actually I saw him
ready
last week they discovered a new worm and
they named it after Conan really yep if
the carnie Gnaeus Conan O'Brien II
basically does it and it eats the eggs
of the spiny impervium lobster do we
know why running with you're right all
right you trying to grab that guy if
ever there's a white circle you can grab
it so you can grab bullets and throw
them back oh really okay now why was the
worm named Africana do not because it's
kind of an orange how you got killed
yeah hey you're back where's my gunga
I'll teleport to continue
see not as easy as it looks no it's not
whoever was giving you laughs a
good normal killing shirt yeah that's
the thing oh no gun that's a love how
they named it robo recall is it like
you're not killing robots
we got here
again if they have if it has a white
circle you can cry there you go
oh you died again do teleport okay
sticky move baby
so that guy you can guys like if they're
close all right if something's close you
can grab it and then it's an easy way to
kill some interviews as a huge white one
like that boy yeah you can throw them
you can rip them apart let's clear it Oh
alright Nick well so for an internship
what do you look for an intern oh god is
gonna be interesting
I show you what I look for an intern is
it about the applications you're asking
or yes yeah so what they have like let's
say I turn in my off again what do you
like to see in an application a common
thing I see is a lot of people because
we're comedy show because you know I get
a lot of people that really try to be
funny in their application right and I
recommend not doing that I think it uh
yeah it's bit where it's show business
you want to go to the left turn Iraq
gonna go the other young see what that
arrows pointing you yes yeah so you want
to go that way guys so yeah so it is
show business this is a professional
rodeo as much as it might not seem like
it is it is I remember when I was in
intern like we would open all the
application wherever one guy just wrote
like I think I'd be job whatever rock
and roll Steve as a rock and roll that's
where you gonna put on a job application
like it's ridiculous oh yeah you want to
see twig our twist of things so it turns
all right you told me that
here we go she's about to get heavy I
just said a lot my lawsuits at you so be
professional guys in your resumes be
professional and I really want to hear
he says he's killing road yeah cuz we're
just going to that's right now do I have
to do I have to be majoring in show
business you do not absolutely not have
to major in show biz is you can be major
in a robotic yeah I mean obviously an
interest is is is helpful I mean we want
you to get as much as you can out of the
internship yeah you could dunk to you
know the right way tied up but actually
Jack in real life I really how do I talk
just duckling a human being keep you in
dude stick and move baby stick and move
stick and move do you got shotguns on
your shoulder too by the way I need
those when you get up close oh yeah
because but yeah just like a regular
shotgun ride that oh it's your right -
alright
nice
how long do internships typically last
typically like a school semester okay we
usually will spring for summer and fall
term there we go
sometimes we have insurance for the
winter that we call wind turns oh there
we go
are you gonna go because over Christmas
and holiday break it's a little hard to
get to schedule people right everyone's
good course so there's a winter in class
it's here a little bit shorter than the
others but you look to your left so dude
weird
is there another dude somewhere I got a
stick admit I can move man always move
always move Oh get it good old winter I
think I was a winter what are you yeah
now there are general production and
specialized right correct yeah so whoa
so what are the differences so general
production it's great because you kind
of get your hands on a little bit of
everything at the show right Jenna
Jennifer actually you kind of get it
it's kind of a back jack-of-all-trades
exactly it's really good if you if
you're not 100% sure what you want to do
and you know you want to work in
entertainment but you don't know exactly
what you want to do an entertainment
right the production internship is great
because you can kind of figure it out in
that time you have time so you have an
idea of what you really excel in yes you
get a flavor for the entire show exactly
which is kind of just catch you can kind
of interact with everybody right so the
other departments do we have a script
Department we have the casting
Department
we have talent that's right we get my
guns real quick we have got the probably
a yeah with are aiming department kind
of surprise props doesn't have an intern
I can what I think and that interesting
I feel like we did a long time ago I
think they had might have something to
help them out but we do not write but in
general production you will certainly
help out the props part you certainly
will mr. bill tell oh wait did I miss
right oceans and if you're hot tarnish
Lansky we will be in his department
which is not really a department it's
just you
- bunch of crazies you want to go
towards towards that end Oh see that
blue arrow that's kind of you wanted
yeah boy oh yeah you're on it so but I
think you got a face you got a face the
other way I see there okay that's dude
wait where oh I don't know some red
arrow dude Oh yellow yes somewhere
unpaid pun based work where I was
looking for unpaid fun baseball but yeah
I mean the thing is like here's what I
love I was an intern here's what I love
talking here it was cool to see the
inner workings of a show because it was
really interesting because it's kind of
like don't really get the true flavor I
mean how could you about how a show is
actually put together and actually works
unless you kind of see behind the scenes
and when you see behind the scenes like
Nick was saying you're really true truly
immediately understand that it's a
business like you know we obviously I
know Nick is killing robots at virtual
reality as part of his workday but we do
work very hard and it is a pretty insane
schedule and crazy and I think like if
you have any interest at all and seeing
how show business works I would highly
recommend being an intern i I wish it I
internship editor get more shows because
every show is completely different even
between like late-night shows like the
way our show is wrong in the way Fallon
show is Ron or Corden like we're all
completely different which is really
interesting so and late-night shows
versus sitcoms versus whatever I mean
you know
you can only help yourself by seeing the
interactions of some others like jobs
you wouldn't even realize our jobs which
is really cool so you know like the
costume department versus the casting
Department completely different even
though they sound similar your step
forward and lift it right leg up
actually went through step over this
very sorry
look your right foot dude they made
Wireless VR is gonna be awesome
that's the only thing I wish like I wish
I was really running around I know that
we're away it sways off on that but that
would be great that's right but this is
awesome this is okay this is Elon Musk's
nightmare like self-aware robot okay
you're trying to basically throw them
all you want to grab robots and oh yeah
I actually have to yeah you have to grab
so get get up close to them and then
there's a white circle you can tap so
grab that guy and then throw them into
this thing so yeah you want to kind of
target one area kind of whip them in
fella for that close to my kind of
punchy
damn I keep thrown it oh god oh god the
come in fast
I got skipping these guys are okay I
love it I was any talent intern which is
cool wait you worried huh
that's true I didn't actually just for a
job it was a little more involved back
in the day because we have like no much
younger staff I also used a typewriter
since I book contract has missed erekle
and I like memorize the exact species I
like that evidence base based have to
have to have space based um but it's
really cool like if you do get to be
neutered I would say you know I just
kind of pretended that I worked here so
I would walk around like helping people
with whatever they needed it's always
amazing to me when it turns kind of just
sit there doing nothing I mean I used to
go over and like ask people can I put
away your tapes can i you know what can
I do for you and they're like oh is that
going to be doing there's always
something to be done and yeah and also
we have a digital book that's okay
you're fine
we also have a digital intern who's cool
like you guys remember Riley who's
running the stream before so yeah the
digital intern gets their hands pretty
dirty helping us with shoots just great
and doing boring work like tagging a
million videos a different tag or going
into removing the commas out of all the
thing you know so but then they also get
to help help set up shoots with Danger
Mouse and all these other things so
which is really cool yeah so it's fun
that uh you know we have a wide range of
internships and shows really but again
like always are on the side of being
professional you can never go wrong
right Nick but being too professional
absolutely that's the key don't worry
there's plenty of time to be cool but
like when I was an intern I was not
funny
I mean I was funny looking so but uh and
you know I just again like I was just I
took it super seriously and you want to
be the intern that like people rely on
which is yeah you want to be the one
that everyone knows yeah yeah that's the
person who we end up hiring very
and also like your thing too is like you
know I think a lot of interns you don't
realize that there are foot is already
in the door like you know we know see
when I go forward the next room they go
take a left go in the batter and go into
the that way but face back this waiver
oh yeah now Nick what if I am not in the
US that would be an intern can we do we
have international insurance or no
unfortunately no unfortunately no
certainly it is no but I know there's a
lot of interest but it is something that
we we cannot accommodate at this time
and it's more because that stuff and why
we asked for school credit might be not
asked but why you have to get beginning
school credit right it's a liability
insurance issue right so you know it's
not even really up to us it's just part
of how it goes right you're working for
the school credit because we can say
that you are that's what you were that's
your payment right that's yeah exactly
so it's like and that's also kind of
covers you if anything bad to happen
because you know we blow up
sometimes we things you know like for
the when Conan was huge driving in the
Batmobile for last year's comic-con with
Ian Roberts
that was amazing we blew up ice cream
truck and that was a thing and agents
were there it was cool so they answered
ring inside the ice cream truck and that
was unfortunate but you know what
that's what it is we had to know if it
was actually gonna we had to know I was
gonna blow her now
yeah you can't they have the light fuses
and make sure the pieces went out know
every bullvine but there you can rip its
head off
let me set up dude like it with a gun oh
yeah oh yeah
um but yeah so that that's the cool
thing cuz yeah things do happen so when
you got to be
well yeah there's all kinds of awesome
internships in the show again one of the
things that didn't happen that I didn't
get to do when I was an intern but it
turns get to now watch rehearsal which
is really fun so you know if you guys
see scraps on our website which by the
way you should go get our pop / Stratus
always alert interns are there and
laughing and a lot of interns are in
scraps because we'll cut to the audience
and they'll just the internet or in
terms will be standing my friend Tony we
news an intern REM was on the show and
Michael Stipe was late and so he stood
in for Michael Stipe while the rest of
REM played a song that is amazing which
is really fun so he has like a video
that there's a really great scrap of it
was all interns filling in for the band
and now they're just playing our
instruments and it's hilarious exactly
yeah that's the most yeah so all right
so I've turned in my internship yes
application how long does it normally
take to go through them or when should
it can I expect a call how does that
work out of the process so unfortunately
it's impossible for me to contact
everybody even if I am NOT going to be
take like I can't always give you the
status update on the application I get a
lot of applications right but I mean
wants to put once the deadline hits you
know if you don't hear anything maybe
within two months then I would say it
didn't happen to son right but yeah
there's some issues like a two-month
window that I do from the deadlines were
posted on Team Coco comm slash
internships and would you say that lets
if I do not get to be an intern this
time should I reapply as I absolutely
okay great absolutely
I should reapply if I if I if I don't
get it this time because a lot of times
there's just factors beyond your control
but how many right I mean there's you
know there is a certain number of course
that we have and then you know I do
there's just a lot of people and there's
a lot of great candidates so I want to
get everybody that I can and that as
long as you and when you apply it you
know again
it shows me that you really wanted as
well I'm not saying send ten
applications each term into mine take a
hint if you don't get it a couple times
well no but I'm saying even some people
like keep sending an application you
know in the same deadline to me say a
deadline I see which is just you know I
don't I don't need that but uh yeah so
if you send an application no that
weekend yeah absolutely I mean how many
stealing mail from Team Coco yeah I'm
seeing every success for me because I
look my sister orders a lot of beauty
products and Amazon so I'll go through
the state I need my moisturizer you know
right but aside from you stealing my
sister's beauty products nobody's
stealing airmail so we get your
application of you senator
absolutely I then what's the process
from there so then you call you call the
people once you select your applicate
your application typically I will reach
out via via email you know one and then
I see you know if there's a time we can
set up the talk maybe do a little either
a Skype interview something or sometimes
just most of the time just a phone
interview sometimes I do Skype yeah and
then that's usually I mean that's
usually it usually I can get enough from
that it's a you know everyone so we do
have the API run a background check
yeah we do that we get your credit your
social security so scurrying over we
steal your identity we become you we
then find a wife / husband and marry
them and start a new life with them we
have a couple kids under your name of
course well you get to be an intern and
it's all worth it yeah then we live out
your entire life under your name and
then give you a tape of what happened
it's very cool
oh I don't have a gun no no you got done
shot shotguns women over your shoulder
how did I do it
oh nice final they're all running now
they're all over this is great
alright one more level man hello guys
again we're here with Nick said to Fonte
who is in charge of a the whole office
but also hiring our interns give any
internship questions hit a self-employed
robo recall on the oculus rift today of
course about Morosky and the chat lemon
have a great question what's a good were
you ever in Simon interview is a great
she wasn't rich favorite intern and has
now graduated to everyone's favorite
employee
just cool which kind of missed me but
what happened here I think you would oh
yeah
anyway you want to turn up turn around
first of all then yeah you fly people
out that's probably not necessary in the
world of Skype no yeah we don't do that
Skype is usually is usually you wanna
use telephone to the noisy
yeah Skype is a virtual fly right yeah
we live in this virtual world so we can
do that you all this thing it is funny
what I'm doing clueless gamer stuff a
lot of times I'll have any terms and
come into play with me oh really yeah
can I just be sometimes I just need
someone to pretend
but interns are 99% 99 that make sense
my favorite moment when I was an intern
was we were shooting the Westminster Dog
the last Westminster dog remote Ashley
Jordan asked if I could go under that I
did which is really fun so I got to ride
the cab like next to Robert Smigel which
was great and then we got kicked out of
the Westminster Dog Show of course but
then we snuck back in and stole part of
like a thing from the Westminster Dog
Show so we can recreate it so we could
recreate it in our studio which didn't
make a lot of sense because you could
just take a photo of it and have like
set make it you know the sec guys so I'm
not sure exactly what I read so I put we
did so fun this can't be forever you
want where it's great trust me
it's the visual of you jumping around it
- which is fun there we go okay there we
go
also if you're wondering about my Robo
killing shirt I got it at Harlem right
down the strip in the Apollo Theater
which extremely exciting okay
my shirt is fun though we pathya tur
Brian Reynolds Louie CK really good time
step take a step okay
Oh anywhere interesting questions and
ask so so far be professional if you
don't get you know selected you can send
in your application again we
unfortunately can't accept international
applications don't sign your signature
rock and roll yeah a lot of questions
about like you need to be in college
like you need to be in college you have
to be any college yes so that's actually
great question because there are we've
had interns that have graduated already
but they still enroll to a to get
college credit somewhere so right a lot
of universities like offer like an
internship credit program where you can
essentially you're just applying
especially you're enrolling to their
school just literally just to get credit
for the internship right it's like you
want to go behind that thing in the
president book now can I be a hype can I
be a high schooler no you can obviously
you have to be getting college credit
correct yes now what am i doing
also another decided to go to college if
you have the means do it oh I see there
we go
sweet I am to defend no that's a big nut
what was the question right yeah can you
make friends with celebs no please place
it under that's kind of what we did not
beat it it's a great way to immediately
leave the internship and there have been
interns who have done their happen which
is like
yeah I don't think I made contact with
happy on the eye contact without the
staff but uh yeah everyone's really
friendly everybody can like it's not
that stuff it's you just can't do it
again we want professionals and you know
people come to our show we want to
provide a safe environment first right
they're here to work as well they want
to keep coming we want them to keep
coming back or want to come back yes I
should move some guy telling you to but
I just like standing I get robo recall
this is one of the most fun games I've
ever played it might not oh that was a
very slow-moving missile did I get it no
this is one of the better VR games I
don't have a ton of experience in the
deal I really like this a lot
but the left you look the left
collective or recall him sorry
him Alex it really was not it's giving a
tense I mean I told Moses fail Oh God
well kids that'll do it for today hope
you love playing now if you love
watching uh watching us play rubble
recall thanks to Nick guys answering all
your internship questions again you can
find more information team koga calm
slash internships
and thank you of course to path Morosky
j7i cooper the corner and make sure to
watch the show tonight we've got who's
on the show of date dangerous and Sam
Cohen Bridget yes friends love rashida
Jones and the other oh my god Neil
deGrasse Tyson rashida Jones Sam Cohen
and and dangerous it's an amazing way to
round out a Wednesday thank you all for
watching and we're off next week so we
will not see you next right are we gonna
do this next week probably off alright
we're probably uh we'll see in two weeks
yeah well he's like nope I'm not gonna
be going to Cabo oh thanks guys see you
guys in two weeks bye
[Music]
you